great to see you on computer file in
this sort of strange uh remote manner
what is it you've got um to talk to us
about there was a
really nice story about uh a real
programmer who
who did all sorts of tricks with things
a guy called mel
kay who worked for the royal mcb
computer company
and uh he he was the ultimate real
programmer and
you can you can follow the story through
but he did some
outrageous things with the machines to
just get them all to work and
there's a number of things we could talk
about but the one i wanted to start with
was
the memory they had at the time which
was all based on drums
drum memory i think it was kind of the
first sort of memory they
ever had there was some stuff i think
dave brailsford
referred to why they actually had
mercury delay lines but they didn't last
very long because
mercury is not easiest thing to work
with so these were sort of the
very first commercial ways of storing
anything at
all so i don't think this video quote is
quite good enough we might have to sort
of pick this up
um yeah so let's pick it up when we've
got everything
all sorted but it sounds like a
fascinating story
okay yeah well i've got some uh examples
that we can put together to
perhaps illustrate some of it and even
some broken hardware that's lying around
including this broken broken disk here
a real programmer is somebody who's not
afraid to use go to's
not afraid to go in and change the
binary code
directly if that's what gets the job
done
probably doesn't use even high-level
languages they probably go straight down
to the metal and they know the
computers intimately so this was uh
brought into sharp contrast by a lovely
story
about a guy named mel who worked for
a californian early
computer manufacturer this is in the
late 1950s
and they had a new computer
and one of the jobs that mel had was to
write a program
to play pontoon or 21 blackjack
so they could use this program when they
took the computer to various shows or to
customers
but this story actually which we'll
probably put a link to
highlights quite a lot of interesting
items about computers so certainly in
the early days
we didn't really even have memory then
well this predates me
so the early computers didn't have what
we
might view as conventional memory as
sort of um
magnetic cores or anything like that or
hard disks
the very earliest computers did a
variety
of things and quite a lot of their own
things but uh fairly early on it was
settled on something called drum
memory and that's what i'd like to talk
about today is the
sort of first introduction to this real
programming and what you could do with
that
to explain drum memory i thought it was
probably
useful to start with something we know
so this this is a hard disk
uh an old one of mine that no longer
works
so i thought if we have a look at it and
explain what's
going on so inside here there's a disk
and
there's a head that reads and writes
from it so let's go and have a look at
that
so there are two important things about
disks
when you're trying to read from them one
is latency
which is while you wait for the
particular bit of the disk you want to
come under the read and write head so
you just have to wait for the disk to
spin round
also on disks there's a seek time which
is while you wait for the arm
with the heads on it to move over to the
bit of the disc
you're going to eventually wait for the
data to come under so this is a hard
disk
drive so you can't do an old one now
don't do this at home because it will
destroy your disk so this is the disk
drive
it has here the heads which are floating
over the
disk so this is the surface of the disk
i think you can see there are several
platters there's not just one single
disc there's actually a stack of them
and each one of those has a different
head
you can see this moves about slightly so
this is the
seek time you've got to move the head
backwards and forwards to come to the
right cylinder
which is the three-dimensional view
downwards
and then you have the latency while you
wait for the
data to come around and come under the
head and then you can read it
now i think we can actually get this to
fire up it's
it's broken so it doesn't actually work
but let's see what we can do plug that
in this is the power supply
and i think if we switch it on
so we can see the disc is now spinning
up you can hear it making a
noise and then we can see the heads
moving
this one's broken so it doesn't actually
ever get there but you can see how
quickly the heads move so
this is what limits how quickly you can
get data from the disk is how quickly it
can spin
so it's spinning pretty rapidly so the
data does come under the
heads quite quickly and then this thing
has to jump around
as quickly as it can to get to the right
part of the disk
so between those two that's what limits
your read speed of the disc
so the drum memory i don't actually have
a drum because they
i think they went out of use finally in
the 1970s
but they were used from about the 1950s
onwards although i think they were
invented in 1930 but this is what a dumb
drum
memory looks like so it's just a drum
with
just like a disc it has magnetic stuff
on it and there would be a read write
head here
so the drum would spin round but the
difference between this
and disc memory is you had a fixed
number of heads you'd have heads that
went all the way down
but these would be positioned like this
over the tracks
and the density wouldn't be anything
like on a hard disk today so the drum
would spin round like this
and what this means is you don't have
any seek time the heads are always
positioned over the numbers or the the
tracks
so all the time you need is just the
latency
for it to spin round and if you want the
for that to come under the head and then
it can read it but there are all sorts
of tricks you can play with this
so if you're a real programmer you know
how long it takes for
an instruction to to work so let's
suppose this 24 here was uh an ad
instruction or something like that and
you just
wanted to add three to a number
something like that
so the drum would come round it would
read that 24
and you would know because you were a
real programmer and you knew
intimately what your machine was capable
of that an ad
instruction might take i don't know 10
milliseconds or something
like that to complete so if it took 10
milliseconds to complete
in 10 milliseconds how much would the
drum rotate
so what you could do if you were a
really good programmer and say well
i know 10 milliseconds is about a
quarter of a rotation or something like
that
i know the heads are going to be sort of
hovering over this position
ready to read it so i do the ad 10
milliseconds i put my next instruction
here
and it's right ready to to run there
if you just sort of put them anywhere on
the the drum
then you might have to wait for it to
rotate completely around
to read it again so
by positioning these instructions on the
drum
you could actually increase your
program speed quite considerably because
everything you needed would be waiting
uh waiting for you so you read your 24
and you
your next one is going to be 30 and by
the time you're ready for it
lo and behold it's there under the uh
under the read head ready to go another
thing that
mel did was uh
they had to print out stuff on a uh
basically a sort of typewriter like
console
and this could only output at a certain
speed so
it would print a you tell it to print
the character a or something like that
and it would print the a but it would
take a few milliseconds to actually
print the a
and then be ready for the next one so
in this case you want to use the drum to
actually slow things down
so in in mel's case he would print the a
and he'd put his next uh command to
maybe print a b or something he'd put it
uh right the way around the other side
of the the drum
so we'd pick up this and say right i'll
print the a
and then it would have to spin all the
way around here before it could pick up
the next instruction which was print b
and this
he could work out was enough time for
the printer to print
the character be ready for the next
instruction
so you could use this for a sort of
delay loop you
instead of having to
what's traditionally done for delay
loops which is just counting up to some
number
you count to 100 or something like that
and that's it done
he didn't need any of that he could just
wait he could say well i know exactly
how long this is going to take to come
around so i'll just wait for that to
come around and then
pick it out and yet another thing he
could do
is um if he wanted to add
just arbitrary numbers to say you've got
a variable and you wanted to add seven
to it
what you could do is say okay i'm going
to write in my program
and add instruction and the number seven
but if you like he did
really knew what your computer is
the instruction set is just a bunch of
numbers so we might have here
24 represents the instruction code for
for an ad
but uh a store instruction might be
encoded as seven so if he wanted to add
um seven to a number then he'd
look around his drum and say well where
have i got a seven that's being used as
a
as a load operation oh it's over here
actually if i position that over here
this will be just perfectly
positioned so just by positioning all
these things in a sort of matrix
uh you can get all sorts of things and
of course you've got lots of positions
you can
move further down the drum i haven't
written them all in down here but
there's all sorts of places you can use
to store them
so those are a couple of tricks that he
used
and if
we'll probably go on and discuss some of
the other tricks that the early
programmers could use to
speed up or slow down or just get the
maximum amount of
ability out of their computer because
you're really very limited in the amount
of storage you've got
and speed is everything at these points
because these computers were not were
running with transistors they were still
running with valves at this point
so every second counted you only have to
work out whether it's worth
alerting the user if you find the key so
you know you download the temporary
exposure key you perform the encryption
you generate the potential rpis and you
compare them with the ones you've seen
or if you want a more slightly
comprehensible message it's saying maybe
you haven't applied a function to
enough arguments